many here believed Japan had been spared
the worst of the pandemic but an
alarming rise in the number of new
infections has prompted Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe to declare a state of
emergency if we can reduce social
contact between people by at least 70
percent or possibly by 80 percent we can
ensure the virus Peaks in two weeks and
that number will decrease the emergency
measures will be enforcing Tokyo Osaka
and five other prefectures but will rely
on people observing them voluntarily
residents can be requested to stay home
except for essential tasks schools can
be closed and public gatherings banned
Lannon buildings can be requisitioned
for emergency hospitals along with food
and medicine but some are concerned it
might not be enough I think it's a bit
late because other countries issued the
state of emergency at a much earlier
stage I think Japan should take tougher
measures like other countries Japanese
companies are suffering this time of
year would normally be busy for this
tour bus firm but business is down by 90
percent
with only two of its fleet of vehicles
out on the road we're asking employees
to take pay cuts in early retirement so
we can survive and see better days but
to do that we need the government to
help us in addition to these emergency
measures the Japanese government has
also announced a stimulus package of
nearly a trillion dollars to help the
economy survive that's double the amount
the country spent on tackling the 2008
financial crisis already hurt by the
postponement of the Summer Olympics the
economy needs help quickly we have one
negative impact after the other so what
is coming now is a huge fiscal package
of 20% of GDP this is totally
unprecedented and it comes much faster
than before the government is appealing
for all Japanese to support its measures
so that weeks after other cities
effectively closed
down still bustling Tokyo may finally
join them aiya Sakura al-jazeera Tokyo